[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem vorletzten Tag des
Jahres rudi zerne ist auch wieder dabei
für den Sport hallo schönen guten Abend
die Überschwemmungen halten viele
Menschen weiter in
Atem vollgesogene Deiche trübe
Aussichten das Hochwasser in
Niedersachsen und anderswo fließt kaum
ab und es drohen weitere
Regenfälle eine Nacht viel Sorge nach
den Ausschreitungen bei den letzten
Silvesterfeiern gilt für morgen
besondere
Alarmbereitschaft Silvester im
Dreivierteltakt die dresner Semperoper
geht mit großen Melodien und großen
Stars der Klassik ins neue
Jahr ein Landkreis in SachsenAnhalt hat
den kastophenfall festgestellt weil die
Hochwasserlage jetzt schon so lange
dauert in Niedersachsen Wissen hunderte
von Menschen nicht wann sie zurück in
ihre Häuser können weiterer Regen ist
angekündigt und das THW rechnet damit
dass der Einsatz bis in die 1
Januarwoche dauert morgen will der
Bundeskanzler ins Hochwassergebiet in
Niedersachsen Reisen vor allem dort
führen die Flüsse weiter Hochwasser
drohen Deiche zu brechen und sind viele
Städte überschwemmt betroffen sind unter
anderem oldenburg Winsen an der Aller
und Zelle Clemens Altmann
berichtet der befürchtete Regen über
Nacht ist ausgeblieben die Pegel an den
Oberläufen der Flüsse in Niedersachsen
sinken leicht aber an den Unterläufen
verharren sie auf höchstem Niveau in
Zelle droh die aller über ihre Ufer zu
treten angesichts der Hochwasserlage
wird vor Ausfällen der Energieversorgung
gewarnt auch das Mobilfunknetz könnte
zusammenbrechen einige Kilometer Fluss
abwärts bei Winsen können die
Einsatzkräfte keine LKW mehr an den
Deich bringen alles steht unter Wasser
der Untergrund ist schlammig
Kettenfahrzeuge übernehmen den Transport
der
Sandsäcke 130 km nordwestlich in hatten
bei Oldenburg ist die Hochwasserlage
weiterhin kritisch der Pegelstand der
Hunte ist unverändert hoch die Folge der
Deich wird weich muss verstärkt werden
der besondere Schutz gilt der Bahnlinie
nach
osnerbrück ein Hubschrauber der der
Bundespolizei fliegt hier und sorgt
dafür dass bigpacks hier vom
Bereitstellungsplatz dann zum Einsatzort
geflogen werden um dann dort den Deich
zu stabilisieren und mit Gewicht halt zu
unterstützen aber die Gefahr ist nicht
gebannt die Stadt Oldenburg bereitet
deshalb eine mögliche Evakuierung des
Stadtteils achterdieg vor Einsatzkräfte
gehen von Haus zu Haus und informieren
die Bewohner in Pferden an der Aller
steht das Wasser schon in den Straßen
ohne Gummistiefel sind die Häuser nicht
mehr zu erreichen und ohne Sandsäcke
wären sie schon
vollgelaufen seit dem 23 werden hier
durchgängig Sandsäcke befüllt die die
Sandsäcke befüllt im minutentagt sag mal
man kalkuliert so die Stunde mit 1000
Sack auch wenn sich die Situation von
gestern zu heute nicht verschärft hat
von Entwarnung ist Niedersachsen weit
entfernt Vorort in der Altstadt von
Ferden ist Senja domeierer wie stark ist
die Altstadt
betroffen hier steht das Wasser
tatsächlich an vielen Häusern bis an die
wie man hinter mir glaube ich ganz gut
sehen kann hier in Pferden mitten in der
Altstadt sind zwei Straßenzüge komplett
betroffen in diesen Straßenzügen sind
keine Geschäftshäuser sondern es sind
Wohnhäuser hier leben die Menschen und
jeder der einen Keller hat der hat die
Pumpen laufen alle Keller hier sind
vollgelaufen die Pumpen laufen Tag und
Nacht entweder der Feuerwehr oder der
Anwohner selbst die darüberliegenden
Stockwerke die sind in der Regel trocken
geblieben da konnten die Anwohner in
ihren Häusern bleiben das war kein
Problem ähm aber ähm ja die Keller sind
auf jeden Fall alle vollgelaufen und äh
die Feuerwehr ist hier die ganze Zeit im
Einsatz was hören sie denn von den
Einsatzkräften die da seit Tagen
schuften die sind verständlicherweise
inzwischen einigermaßen erschöpft und
man muss leider sagen sie berichten viel
von Gaffern von Störern die ihre Arbeit
dann doch behindern die Leute stellen
sich entweder mit Autos in den Weg sie
kommen um Fotos oder Filmaufnahmen zu
machen um Handyvideos zu machen sie
durchbrechen Absperrung oder laufen über
Deiche das ist natürlich nicht so schön
das behindert die Arbeiten und geht bei
Hochwasser einfach gar nicht aber es
gibt auch die positiven Berichte es gibt
die guten Geschichten nämlich von der
großen Hilfe untereinander erstens
helfen sich die Einsatzkräfte
gegenseitig wahnsinnig und jetzt seit
über einer Woche Tag und Nacht und auch
die Bevölkerung ist hier absolut präsent
wir haben vorhin hier mehrere Menschen
gesehen die mit Bollerwagen durch die
Straßen ziehen heiße Getränke anreichen
oder Gebäck und das hält dann doch die
Moral der eins satzkräfte wirklich oben
man sieht sich gut gerüstet für die
Silvesternacht und auch für den Anfang
des kommenden Jahres vielen Dank für
diese Eindrücke ausferden Svenja domer
war
das der viele Regen macht auch anderswo
Probleme die Zugverbindung zwischen
Großbritannien und dem europäischen
Festland ist seit dem Morgen
unterbrochen in der Nähe von London
Drang so viel Wasser in zwei Tunnel ein
dass die Eurostar Züge zwischen der
britischen Hauptstadt und dem Ärmelkanal
nicht mehr fahren können
tausende Reisende sitzen fest vor allem
in London Paris und wie hier in Brüssel
äußerste Wachsamkeit und hartes
Durchgreifen bei Attacken gegen die
Polizei das kündigte Innenministerin
fäser im Tagesspiegel für die
Silvesternacht an die Polizei ist in
Alarmbereitschaft nach den Krawallen im
vergangenen Jahr will man gewappnet sein
für ähnliches und für Anschläge in Köln
hatte es vor Weihnachten Hinweise auf
einen möglichen Plan einer
islamistischen Gruppe gegeben seither
wird der Dom noch intensiver beobachtet
Alexander röttig berichtet die
Domschweizer in ihren roten Roben als
Türwächter das reicht in diesen Tagen
nicht mehr nur angemeldete Besucher und
die müssen anstehen zum Sicherheitscheck
durch schwer bewaffnete
Polizeibeamte morgen gilt hier in der
Kölner Innenstadt ein böllerverbot dazu
Videoüberwachung und Polizisten mit
Maschinenpistolen Terrorgefahr Symbol
trechtigkeit des Kölner Doms müssen wir
dabei ein bisschen im Blick behalten so
dass das nicht nur im Inneren und am
engsten Bereich des Domes zu Anschlägen
kommen könte sondern auch auf
Menschenmengen die sich in der Nähe
aufhalten Essen vor einem Jahr hier
schossen Randalierer mit Raketen auf
Feuerwehrleute und Polizisten die sie
schütenten ein böllerverbot gibt es hier
nicht kaum flächcken durchzusetzen so
die Einschätzung der Behörden eine
Herausforderung für die Polizei die
beobachtet auch ob der Krieg in Gaza
instrumentalisiert wird die politische
Lage wird von der Polizei natürlich
stetig auch mit in unsere Bewertung mit
einbezogen sollten sich im Vorfeld
Hinweise auf mögliche Konflikte während
der Silvesternacht ergeben werden wir
unsere Maßnahmen natürlich auch anpassen
und entsprechend darauf reagieren ob NRW
oder Berlin alle Bundesländer bereiten
sich auf eine unruhige Silvesternacht
vor rüsten technisch und personell auf
wir werden mit mehr Polizisten da sein
500 mehr als letztes Jahr
6600 männer und Frauen sind unterwegs
sind auch so eingesetzt dass sie
flexibel verschiebbar sind wenn Notlagen
es machen nach den Ausschreitungen im
vergangenen Jahr wollen die Behörden
kein Risiko eingehen allein in Köln
sollen 1000 Polizisten die Feiernden
Schützen eine Garantie dafür dass es
ruhig bleibt ist aber auch das
nicht der UN Sicherheitsrat hat die
schwersten russischen Luftangriffe auf
die Ukraine seit Kriegsbeginn
mehrheitlich verurteilt dabei waren
gestern nach ukrainischen Angaben
mindestens 39 Menschen getötet und mehr
als 160 verletzt worden in der Nacht
setzte Russland seine Attacken fort
heute meldeten russische Behörden einen
ukrainischen Angriff auf die grenznahe
Stadt belgorot durch Bomben sein 14
Menschen getötet und 108 verletzt worden
Moskau hat mit Vergeltung gedroht und
fordert eine Sondersitzung des
unserheitsrats zum Krieg in narost
Israel kämpft nicht nur im Gazastreifen
auch die Spannungen an der Grenze etwa
200 km nördlich nehmen zu dort wird
Israel fast täglich und auch heute
wieder mit geschossen angegriffen
abgefeuert aus dem Libanon von der
Terrororganisation Hisbollah sie
dominiert den Libanon militärisch als
Miliz und zugleich politisch als
islamistische Partei verbündet ist die
hisbolla mit Iran und mit der
terrormiliz Hamas aus dem Norden Israels
berichtet Henriette
deier Straßensperren am Eingang Gang der
Stadt kiriat schmunna nur wenige leben
derzeit hier rund 100.000 Menschen
wurden aus der gesamten Grenzregion
evakuiert hier so zeigt schual sind vor
drei Tagen Raketen aus dem Libanon
eingeschlagen wie fast jeden Tag doch
die Hauptsorge der Menschen im Norden
sei dass die hisbolla ins Land eindringt
im Moment spricht man von einer
Waffenruhe aber die hisbolla lauert
direkt hinter der Grenze und Sie werden
das machen was die Hamas am 7 Oktober
gemacht hat uns attackieren das gleiche
wird auch hier geschehen die Kriegsangst
allgegenwärtig die Straßen hier sind
gespenstisch leer kiriat mon ist
evakuiert denn täglich gibt es hier
Beschuss aus dem Gebiet des Libanon das
Militär ist hier verstärkt worden wir
hören aus Militärkreisen auch die
Luftwaffe sei bereit Israel ist seit dem
7 Oktober
2023 gewah die die die Möglichkeiten
haben anzugreifen werden dies auch tun
die Armee sei deshalb in sehr hoher
Bereitschaft z
verteig die Idee im Moment ist derzeit
dass wir eine defensive Haltung
einnehmen aber diese
Verteidigungshaltung ist nur so gut wie
sie anhält denn sie könnte außer
Kontrolle geraten und die Situation sehr
herausfordernd werden denn immer wieder
gibt es Provokationen aus dieser
libanesischen Moschee sollen vor ein
paar Tagen Raketen auf Israel gefeuert
worden sein ein hisbolla Führer droht
wir fürchten weder Israel noch
Amerika ich würde dem Liban übernehmen
Sie die Kontrolle über die hboll und
lassen Sie sich nicht von ihnen in
diesen Krieg für den Iran oder die Hamas
hineinziehen und so wächst mit den
Spannung zwischen Israel und der
hisbolla im Libanon die Sorge um eine
weitere Kriegsfront im Nahen
Osten blicken wir nach Belgrad in die
serbische Hauptstadt in der gerade
täglich tausende protestieren der Grund
mutmaßlicher betrug bei der Parlaments
und Kommunalwahl Mitte Dezember schon
vorher regte sich Widerstand eg den
zunehmend autoritären Kurs der rechten
Regierung wuic eigentlich sollten die
Neuwahlen die Lage beruhigen doch heute
fand der größte Protest seitd dem statt
Britta
Hilpert nach 12 Tagen Hungerstreik kann
marinika t kaum noch gehen so
protestiert sie gegen das Wahlergebnis
vom 17 Dezember tausende protestierten
heute
ebenfalls diese Wahlen müssen annulliert
werden GZ wissen dass in diesem Staat
der eukandidat ist Wahlen gestohlen
werden wir kämpfen für Gerechtigkeit und
unsere Stimmen so wie schon einmal vor
Jahren unfair waren die Wahlen stellten
auch die Wahlbeobachter der OSZE fest
vor allem wegen der medialen
Allgegenwart von Präsident wuc
unabhängige serbische Beobachter
berichten auch von Gewalt von
Stimmenkauf und davon wie zahlreiche
Busse mit aus anderen Ländern nach
Belgrad kamen um hier
abzustim ihr seid für die Wahlen da
fragt der Filmende ja bestätigen die
Passagiere kaum ein Tag in Belgrad ohne
Protest gestern eine Straßenblockade
letzte Woche kam es sogar zu Gewalt die
Wahlen verschärfen den Konflikt in und
um Serbien Russland unterstützt wic und
dessen Erzählung von Protesten die aus
dem Ausland gesteuert sind
sie sind eher das Produkt geopolitischer
Umstände so wuic wo manche versuchen
Serbiens Unabhängigkeit und Souveränität
zu zerstören ich stimme nicht zu steht
auf den roten Karten der Demonstranten
sie halten diese Wahlen für
undemokratisch und wollen weiter
demonstrieren
übermorgen ändert sich nicht nur die
Jahreszahl sondern es treten auch
etliche Neuerungen in Kraft so steigt
z.B das Pflegegeld auch können Eltern
mehr kinderkrankentage in Anspruch
nehmen vieles wird aber auch teurer
Peter Tyson hat
Details Benzin Diesel tanken wird wohl
teurer
2024 Grund der CO2 Preis steigt zum 1
Januar von 30 auf 45 € auch das Heizen
dürfte dadurch erheblich kostspieliger
werden wenn man jetzt so etwa 20.000
Kilowattstunden das ist so ein üblicher
Verbrauch in ein Familienhaus
hat dann bedeutet das Mehrkosten von
beim Gas etwa ja so 70 72 € und beim Öl
etwa 95 € mehr kosten pro Jahr das lang
umstrittene sogenannte heizungsgesetz
tritt in Kraft erst einmal nur für
Neubaugebiete zu 65% muss die Energie
nun aus erneuerbaren Quellen stammen im
sozialen Bereich kommt die Erhöhung des
Bürgergeldes es steigt für
Alleinstehende von derzeit 502 auf 563 €
für Paare von 902 auf
102 Thema Steuer der Grundfreibetrag
steigt für Alleinstehende auf 11604 für
Paare auf
23208 €. auch beim Einkaufen gibt es ein
paar kleine Änderungen zu beachten so
wird auf Plastikflaschen mit Milch oder
milchmixgetränken nun Pfand erhoben es
führt hoffentlich auch dazu dass mehr
Einwegverpackung zurückgebracht werden
und nicht irgendwo im Müll landen und
dann äh als
mikroplastik z.B die Meere verschmutzen
zum Jahreswechsel steigt auch die
Mehrwertsteuer für Speisen in der
Gastronomie wieder auf vorcoronaniveau
viele Restaurantbetreiber dürften die
Erhöhung an ihre Kunden weitergeben
insgesamt wird also vieles teurer im
neuen
Jahr viele Änderungen viele Zahlen wir
haben die wichtigsten Informationen fürs
nächste Jahr zusammengefasst online und
in unserer App zum Nachlesen und
durchklicken vom Bürgergeld bis zur
energiepreisbremse traditionell zum
Jahreswechsel bietet die sempaoper in
Dresden opulente
silvesterkonzerte die Besetzung ist
nicht nur hochkarätig sondern nähert
auch Hoffnung ein Russe dirigiert ein
Ukrainer singt begleitet von starpianist
Igor leevt besonders schön morgen können
hier im ZDF alle live dabei sein Anja
chal gibt einen kleinen Vorgeschmack
Silvester ein rauschendes Fest der
Lebensfreude in der dresner Semperoper
unsterbliche Melodien von Oper bis
Operette natürlich auch von Johann Strau
am Pult der dresner Staatskapelle der
russische Dirigent
tuganok mus Musik hat die fantastische
Gabe die Seele zu berühren ohne
Worte me Musik hören würden könnten wir
alle bessere Menschen sein also lasst
sie Teil unseres Lebens werden welster
Igor Levit spielt Mozarts Klavierkonzert
Nummer 21 eine Ode an die
[Musik]
Liebe in diesem Haus zu sein mit diesem
Orchester mit diesem Dirigenten mit
diesem Stück zu diesem andlass macht
mich einfach sehr froh mit sichtlicher
Begeisterung verzaubert die Sopranistin
Golda Scholz das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Publikum Melodien die ein jeder kennt
und deren mitreißender Wirkung man sich
kaum entziehen kann ein wahres Feuerwerk
entfacht die dresner Staatskapelle an
Silvester
[Musik]
2023 genau wir galoppieren hier schon
mit im takagt das Silvesterkonzert aus
der Semper Oper morgen live um 17:300
hier im ZDF und ein Feuerwerk des Jubels
gab es gestern schon beim Skispringen
genau für Andreas Wellinger nach Platz 1
in Obersdorf es war auch der große
emotionale Moment den sich Schispringer
Andreas Wellinger so sehr herbeigesehend
hatte mit dem Auftakterfolg bei der vi
schanzenturnee in Obersdorf zählt er zu
den Mitfavoriten auf den Gesamtsieg zum
Durchatmen bleibt aber kaum Zeit morgen
geht es in gamisch mit der Qualifikation
zum Neujahrsspringen weiter Euphorie um
Wellinger am Schattenberg in Oberdorf
heute bei der Ankunft in
garmischpartenkirchen wirkt er schon
wieder im Tunnel gestern gelingt ihm
endgültig der Sprung zurück in die
Weltelite ein Triumph der sehr viel
zählt das ist unfassbar die die Stimmung
zumnnen das ist das Schönste was man als
deutsche Springer erleben darf in und
auf der Erfolgsspur segelt Wellinger
beim ersten Sprung
139 m weit das beeindruckt auch den
sonst so kritischen Bundestrainer
fantastisch da warlich der Beste was er
gemacht hat zweite war ganz optimal aber
war unter sehr schwi schwierigen
Bedingungen seinen Vorsprung nur
1,66 will er am Neujahrstag mit einem
weiteren siegus bauen dann erklingt auch
wieder die Hymne für
[Musik]
ihn in Toblach ist die 18 Auflage der
Tour de Ski gestartet im Sprint der
freien Technik siegte bei den Männern
Lukas chavana Luca chavana aus
Frankreich bester DSV Läufer wird Marius
Kastner als 15 bei den Frauen schafft es
ketta ritzek hier ganz oben im Bild wie
auch Victoria Karl ins Halbfinale ritzek
wird als beste deutsche siebte das
Finale cheidet Lin Swan aus Schweden für
sich im Fotofinish gegen ihre Landsfrau
Olympiasiegerin Jonna
sündling auftagtssieg fürs deutsche
Tennisteam beim United Cup in Sydney
gegen Italien verliert Angeli Kerber bei
ihrem Comeback nach eineinhalb Jahren
ihr Einzel Alexander zwerev gewinnt sein
Match und im entscheidenden Doppel siegt
das deutsche Duo Kerber zwerev deutlich
mit 6:3 und 6:0 gegen Angelica moratelli
und Lorenzo sonego Kerber bekam
überraschend den Vorzug vor
doppelspezialistin Laura Siegemund
nächster Gegner an Neujahr ist
Frankreich und wieder hat es einen
Favoriten bei der darz WM in London
erwischt Titelverteidiger Michael Smith
aus England ist im Achtelfinale
ausgeschieden souverän weitergekommen
hingegen ist der Niederländer Michael
van
geren er spielt sich mehr und mehr in
die Favoritenrolle auf den
Weltmeistertitel Michael vanaven
der Niederländer schlägt den zuvor im
Turnier stark auftrumpfenden Steven
bting klar in 4:0 setzen der Engländer
chancenlos gegen die wurfgewalt des
dreimaligen Weltmeisters van gven damit
ohne Satzverlust im Viertelfinale trifft
nun auf Scott Williams den Bezwinger von
Martin
Schindler raus dagegen der aktuelle
Titelträger Weltmeister Michael Smith
bereits formschwach ins Turnier
gestartet verliert das englische
achtelfinalduell gegen Chris Doby
deutlich mit 0
Z4 Michael van geren natürlich das war's
vom Sport danke schön und wir gucken
noch auf einen großen Kicker pel
besonders in seiner Heimat Brasilien
beten sie ihn an deshalb lag es für die
Menschen am Zuckerhut nah in jetzt ein
Jahr nach seinem Tod so zu ehren die
Christusstatue in Rio de Janeiro strahlt
im gelben nationaltriko Brasiliens
natürlich mit der Zeh in der er immer
auflief und sich unsterblich machte obs
Fußball gotott pel gefallen hätte er war
ja eher
beschreiben zu Silvester kommt von
Westen neuer Regen auf mehr dazu gleich
von Christa Orben das heute journal um
11:415 Uhr mit Christian sieers wir
danken für Ihr Interesse und wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
tschüss
guten Abend + 2,4° bei der Temperatur
20% beim Regen + 15% beim Sonnenschein
das ist die Bilanz von
2023 und damit ist es das wärmste Jahr
dem Klimawandel geschuldet und auch das
sechst nasseste seit Aufzeichnungsbeginn
in der kommenden Nacht macht der Regen
aber weiter Pause es gibt nur leichten
Nieselregen im Nordosten im Süden kllar
es auch mal auf an den Flüssen bildet
sich Nebel bei leicht frostigen -3°
südlich der Donau und + 8° am niederrein
morgen Vormittag ist es erstmal
weitestgehend trocken mit Sonne im Osten
und im Süden im Westen macht sich aber
schon das dichte Wolkenband bemerkbar
dass dann nachmittags mit schauerartigem
Regen und auch mit kurzen Gewittern nach
Osten durchzieht dazu ist es windig aus
Süd und recht mild bei 5 bis 12°. und
nicht allzu kühl ist auch der
Jahreswechsel in der Silvesternacht bei
2 bis 8° es ist zwar mal böhig mal
windig mit Schauern im Nordwesten und im
Südosten aber diese Regenmengen sind
eigentlich vernachlässigbar das sind
nicht mehr als 1 bis 5 Liter pro
Quadratmeter auch noch am Neujahrstag
mit der Vorgeschichte des Hochwassers
allerdings ist dann doch jeder Liter
relevant zumal es am Dienstag und am
Mittwoch nach aktuellem Stand auch noch
mal zu Dauerregen kommen kann
nichtsdestotrotz wünschen wir ihnen vom
ganzen wetterteam ein frohes neues
Jahr